new at 11 o'clock a police pursuit that
starts in North Las Vegas ends across
state lines it began about 4 30 this
afternoon when police say an armed
robber held up a cell phone store up
here on Ann Road near Decatur North Las
Vegas Police located the suspect's car
several blocks away but then they just
took off now the pursuit going through
the South part of the valley including
the strip Corridor at one point and
involves several local police
departments the suspects then carjacked
another car here along Blue Diamond Road
and then took off to Pahrump where they
tried to apparently carjack somebody
else Nye County deputies chased them all
the way to California the suspects were
finally caught in Baker and they're
currently Behind Bars tonight